well under the law the president is
supposed to be the only person in the
United States who can authorize the use
of a nuclear weapon but one of the
challenges throughout the Cold War to
the present day has been well what if
there was an enemy attack and the
president's killed how do we retaliate
with nuclear weapons so beginning in the
Eisenhower administration the decision
was made for the president to pre
delegate his authority to use nuclear
weapons to other officials down the
chain of command and that would mean
that if the White House was destroyed
and the president was killed that there
would be officers in the military who
knew the codes and had the ability to
launch nuclear weapons in retaliation
the problem becomes though with command
and control how far down the line do you
pre delegate that authority and if you
give junior officers access to the codes
what's going to prevent them from
deciding on their own one day two just
launched a few nuclear weapons and that
sort of dilemma of maintaining
presidential authority and also
maintaining the ability to retaliate has
never been fully resolved the film dr.
Strangelove was brutally attacked by the
Pentagon by the Air Force when it was
released because the central plot
element of dr. Strangelove is that a
crazed American general is going to try
to start World War 3 by ordering
American bombers to attack the Soviet
Union without the president's approval
and the Pentagon said that was
ridiculous and the Air Force said that
was ridiculous and that could never
happen we now know as a result of
declassified documents that the basic
scenario of dr. Strangelove was entirely
possible and it wasn't until the early
1970s that there were any locks on our
nuclear weapons to prevent bomber crews
or missile crews from using them again
you know there was this concern during
the Cold War that the president would be
killed and there'd be no way to use
these
weapons so as recently as 1970 1971 if
an American bomber crew on its own had
decided to fly to Moscow and bomb Moscow
or an American bomber crew had decided
to fly to Chicago and bomb Chicago with
nuclear weapons there was nothing
physically to prevent them from doing it
there was nothing physically to prevent
missile officers from just turning their
keys and launching their missiles
whenever they wanted to the only thing
that stopped that was the
professionalism and the discipline of
our military forces and I give the
military great credit for you know
training their troops and training their
officers so that never happened but
that's an enormous responsibility and an
enormous power to be vested in officers
who were 23 24 25 years old and it only
took during the Cold War in terms of our
missiles two guys
if two guys in their underground command
center had decided hey let's nuke the
Soviet Union there was nothing to
prevent those two guys working in
concert from turning the keys and
launching their missiles so ideally you
would not have the power to kill
hundreds of thousands or millions of
people vested in two young guys and it's
still unnerving that the President of
the United States one man one woman has
the ability without a formal declaration
of war to make a decision that could
kill millions of people
you